how do you
intuit the 10-dimensional
world so yes it's a feature for
describing certain phenomena
like the the entropy in black holes
but what uh you said that
to you a theory becomes
real or becomes powerful when you can
connect it to some
deep intuition so how do we intuit 10
dimensions
yes so i will i will explain how
some of the analogies work first of all
we do a lot of analogies
and by analogies we build intuition so i
will i will start with this example
i will try to explain that if we are in
10-dimensional space
if we have a seven-dimensional plane and
eight-dimensional plane
we ask typically in what space do they
intersect each other in what dimension
that might sound like how do you
possibly give an answer to this
so we start with lower dimensions we
start with two dimensions we say if you
have one dimension
and a point do they intersect typically
in a on a plane the answer is no
so a line one dimensional a point zero
dimension
on a two-dimensional plane they don't
typically meet but if you have a
one-dimensional line and another
line which is one plus one on a plane
they typically intersect
at a point typically means if you're not
parallel typically they intersect at a
point
so one plus one is two and in two
dimension
they intersect at the zero dimensional
point so you see two dimension
one and one two two minus two is zero so
you get point
out of intersection okay let's go to
three dimension
you have a plane two dimensional plane
and a point do they intersect no two and
zero
how about a plane and a line a plane is
two dimensional and a line is one two
plus one is three
in three dimension a plane and a line
meet at points
which is zero dimensions three minus
three is zero okay
so plane and the line intersect at the
point in three dimensions how about the
plane on a plane in three d
my plane is two and this is two two plus
two is four
in 3d 4 minus 3 is one they intersect on
a one-dimensional line
okay we're beginning to see the pattern
okay now come to the question we're in
ten dimensions now we have the intuition
we have a seven dimensional plane and
eight dimensional plane in ten dimension
they intersect on a plane what's the
dimension what's 7 plus 8 is 15 minus 10
is 5.
we draw the same picture as two planes
and we write seven dimension eight
dimension but we have gotten the
intuition from the lower dimensional one
what to expect it doesn't scare us
anymore
so we draw this picture we cannot see
all the seven dimensions by looking at
this
two-dimensional visualization of it but
it has all the features we want
it has so i we draw this picture which
is seven seven and they they meet at the
five dimensional plane
it says five so we have we have built
this intuition now
this is an example of how we come up
with intuition
let me give you more examples of it
because i think this will show you that
people have to come up with intuitions
to visualize that otherwise we
will be a little bit uh lost so what you
just
described is kind of uh in these high
dimensional spaces focus on the meeting
place of uh two planes and high
dimensional spaces
exactly how the planes meet for example
what's the dimension of their
intersection and so on so how do we come
up with intuition we
borrow examples from door dimensions
build up intuition and
draw the same pictures as if we are
talking about
10 dimensions but we are drawing the
same as a two-dimensional plane because
we cannot do any better
but our our words change
but not our pictures so your senses we
can have a deep understanding
of reality by looking at its at slices
a lower dimensional slice exactly
exactly and this this is that comes
brings me to the next example i want to
mention
which is fear let's think about how do
we think about this fear
well the sphere is a sphere you know the
round nice thing but sphere has a
circular symmetry
now i can't describe the sphere in the
following way i can describe it
by an interval which is
think about this going from the north of
the sphere to the south
and at each point i have a circle
attached to it
so you can think about the sphere as a
line with a circle attached with
each point the circle shrinks to a
circle string to a point
at endpoints of the interval so i can
say oh one way to think about the sphere
is an interval where at each point on
that interval there's another circle i'm
not drawing
but if you like you can just draw it say
okay i won't draw so from now on
is this mnemonic i draw an interval when
i want to talk about the sphere and you
remember
that the endpoints of the interval mean
a strong circle that's all
and they say yeah i see that's a sphere
good now we want to talk about the
product of two spheres
that's four dimensional how can i
visualize it easy you just take an
interval and it's another interval
that's just going to be a square yeah
a square is a four dimensional space
yeah why is that
well at each point on the square
there's two circles one for each of
those directions you drew
and when you get to the boundaries of
each direction one of the circles shrink
on each edge of that square
and when you get to the corners of the
square all both circles shrink
this is a sphere times a sphere i have
divine interval
i just described for you a four
dimensional space do you want a six
dimensional space no problem
take the take a corner of a room in fact
if you want to have a sphere times the
stick take sphere times the sphere times
the sphere
take a cube a cube
is a rendition of this six dimensional
space
two sphere times another sphere times on
the sphere where three of the circles
i'm not drawing for you
for each one of those directions there's
another circle but each time you get to
the boundary of the cube one circle
shrinks
when the boundaries meet two circuit
strings when three boundaries meet
all the three circles shrink so i just
give you a picture now
mathematicians come up with amazing
things like you know what i want to take
a point in space
and blow it up you know these concepts
like topology and geometry complicated
how do you do
in this picture it's very easy blew it
up in this picture means the following
you think about this cube you go to the
corner and you chop off a corner
chopping off the corner replaces the
point yeah you raise the point by
triangle
yes that's called blowing up a point and
then this triangle is what they call p2
projective two space
but these pictures are very physical and
you feel it there's nothing amazing
i'm not talking about 6 dimension 4 plus
6 is 10 the dimension of string theory
so we can visualize that no problem
you